it's Kennedy reporting from graceland
for the White House we are a few weeks
into the automatic budget cuts known as
sequestration President Obama and
Democrats warn the cuts would be
destructive in devastating they even
canceled White House tours to show how
brutal life could be how horrible is
life now in the nation's capital we
decided to ask around he does not affect
me at all what are you going to take a
tour the White House we were ru bomb
they shut down the tours we're
disappointed they shut down the tours
yes I'm disappointed in it I think that
it's ridiculous that we can't find a
common ground on anything uh you know
that would have been great but I'm
thinking my voting record wouldn't get
me in to begin with the director of the
National Zoo told The Washington Post
that he feared he might eventually have
to shut down popular exhibits like the
lions and tigers Homeland Security
Secretary Janet Napolitano told
travelers to expect much longer lines at
airports due to cuts to TSA but so far
so good here stopping tours of the White
House like let's be honest is that
really like gonna get us the 85 billion
dollars back I feel it's a farce to
think that our country can cut back up a
half a percent or a percent and a half
do you think there's 85 billion dollars
to cut out of the federal budget or has
it been whittled to the bone oh it's i'm
close to whittle to the bone that's
right syndicate of course the sequester
is only a few weeks old so it's full
effects have yet to be felt but maybe by
summer the TSA lines will be out the
door and the only thing open at the zoo
will be the reptile house until that
happens all we can do is keep calm and
carry on for recent TV I'm Kennedy